سيد
جبارين قبل وصول رد حماس الى الاسرائيليين
كانت قد رشحت جمله من التقديرات
للاسرائيليين حول مضمون او ما يمكن ان
يكون عليه هذا الرد بناء على تلك
التقديرات والمواقف الاسرائيليه على
انقسامها كيف سيتعاملون الان مع هذا
الرد نعم تحياتي استاذه مريم وصباح الخير
لك وضيفك الكريم طبعا بطبيعه الحال بعيدا
عن حذر كله حتى يعني نتنياهو حاول ان يقود
حمله ممنهجه ضد هذه الصفقه على امل بدايه
ان يحاول ان يصفد كل التوترات المتواجده
لديه في داخل الشارع وكذلك ربما حتى هنالك
من يقول انه ادار حمله ممنهجه ضد اهالي
الاصر بمفهوم كهذه او كاخر هذا من جهه
اخرى ومن جهه ثانيه هو كان يتلاعب
ب يعني باستراتيجيه بان ياتي اللا من قبل
حماس هذا ما كان ينتظره على طول ه كل هذه
الطريق بنيامين نتنياهو وبالتالي يعود الى
الشارع الاسرائيلي ويقول لهم لست انا
المشكله بل هو الطرف الاخر هذه
الاستراتيجيه التي كان يود ان يتلاعب بها
حماس في اكثر من موضع في خلال غضون العشر
ايام الاخيره منذ قمه باريس ايه ردت يعني
او لعبت بذات الاستراتيجيه مع بنيامين
نتنياهو وعادت اليه الكره في اكثر من مره
بذات الاستراتيجيه وبالتالي هذا الامر ادى
الى ضعف موقفه اصلا امام الشارع
الاسرائيلي ولهذا السبب بنى بيني جانس على
هذه المرحله فقط على امر واحد ليس الا هو
ان يخرج المستوى العسكري ويقول ان هنالك
امكانيه لتحقيق الاهداف التي لم يتم
تحقيقها على مدار 123 يوم 124 يوم حتى
الان هنالك امكانيه الان تحقيقها في داخل
واجتثاثها من المراحل الاخيره لهذه الحرب
اذا كان هنالك هذا الامر هذا كان ممكن ان
يعطي بيني جانس حتى
موقفا نوعا ما ممكن ان يكون مناهضا لموقف
بنيامين نتنياهو بمفهوم كهذا او كاخر لكن
الكل يعلم ان حتى على المستوى الامني
العسكري الاستراتيجي اسرائيل وهذا ربما
قاله على اكثر من لسان حتى لسان يوسي كوهن
اسرائيل استراتيجيا خسرت هذه الحرب لا
تستطيع ان تتعامل بفوق سلاح الجو وتقول
انها انتصرت او او بيتت انتصارا بالغا
الانتصار الوحيد هو فقط لفوق سلاح الجو
ليس الا وبالتالي ضمن هذه المضامين
اسرائيل تبحث عن كيفيه النزول من على
الشجره ايا كانت الشجره وهي تعلم ان احد
اهم الامور ان اسرائيل ككل هي ممسوكه ك
ينه بيد بنيامين نتنياهو واتلاف بنيامين
نتنياهو وا يمينه طبعا جزء من الحمله التي
كنا قد ذكرناها انا باعتقادي يمكن ان نضم
اليها تصريحات بنفير في نهايه المطاف
كانها جزء من كل هذه الحمله الممنهجه كان
هنالك نوع ما يمكن القول نوع من التلاعب
بالمواقف والادوار ما بين بنيامين نتنياهو
وبين جبر اذ يمكن القول ان في نهايه
المطاف الكلب الذي ينبح وهو مثل بالعبري
الكلب الذي ينبح لا يعض وعلى هذا الامر
يمكن المراهنه على كل موقف بين كبير انه
نعم انه جس كل الخطوط الحمراء ب حتى يمكن
ان يقول انه تجاوز احدها مع الاداره
الامريكيه بمفهوم كهذا او كاخر لكن واضح
والكل يعلم في داخل اسرائيل وبين فير نفسه
يعلم ان ايه ايه الشباك الزمني لتواجده في
داخل الائتلاف هو ربما هذا قد يكون الشباك
الزمني الاخير على مدى العشر
سنوات القادمه فبالتالي كل المعادله الان
هي المحاوله بان
هذا الشباك الزمني على اق قدر اكبر قدر
ممكن حتى عام 2025 عا تاريخ الانتخابات
المقبله و وحتى اذا يجب محاوله اداره عامل
الزمن ليس الا و حتى وان ذهبت اسرائيل
بالتالي اذا هذه الصفقه واضح جدا انا
اوافق هنا كذلك مع ما جاء منما قبل ان
بينغ فير لن يتخلى عن بنيامين نتنياهو
ولكن سوف تكون هنالك ابتزازات في الضفه
الغربيه بالذهاب الى هذه الصفقه وقبول
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بهذه الصفقه هل ستبقى
هناك حكومه اصلا يعني بانتهاء الحرب ربما
سيكون ذلك ما يمكن ان يوصف بالانتحار
السياسي لبنيامين نتنياهو بالتالي كيف
سيدير هذه المساله بين مواقفه والمتشددين
معه بخصوص هذه الحرب
وبين الاستجابه لهذا الاتفاق والذهاب الى
هذه الصفقه مع كل الشروط التي وضعتها حركه
حماس
يعني منان هو متواجد الان امام مفترق طرق
اما ان يختار ما يعني الجزره والعرض
الامريكي المتواجد الان على الطاوله و وان
كان هنالك بعض النفي يعني الاشاعات التي
استغلتها اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
بجزئيه التطبيع مقابل القبول ببعض الشروط
التي يمكن تسويقها ك مساله تسويق لداخل
الشرع الاسرائيلي والتي ممكن ان يستغيث
اجزاء كبيره حتى من داخل اليمين باعاده
مركزه اسرائيل على
الخارطه وبثها وكانها ضعف للقضيه
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي هذا الامر كان ما
يبني عليه بنيامين نتنياهو في اتمام هذه
الصفقه واما ان يختار بكل معنى الكلمه
الذهاب مع بينك في وس موتش وضرب الصفقه
بعرض هذه الحائط ولكن هنالك يعلم انه في
نهايه المطاف هو امام اشكال تين اثنتين
الاولى هي جزئيه
ان كل تمسك بيني جانس في هذه الحكومه بات
واضحا ان القدر الاكبر هو فقط لجزئ الاسرى
لان الجبهه الشماليه بيتت بمفهوم كهذا او
كاخر والجزئيه الثانيه هي قضيه التمرد في
داخل الليكود يجب ان نتذكر ان التمردات في
داخل الليكود بالذات في المواقف الصعبه هو
امر كلاسيكي عام 2006 كان اخرها وقادها ان
ذاك بنيامين نتنياهو نفسه فلا يوجد هنالك
اي مانع من ان يقود جالانت مثل هذا الامر
وهو الذي يطمع لان يكون شارون المقبل
بمفهوم كهذا او كاخر اها